Benvenuti ad un nuovo episodio della h.o
con Karim Musa oggi voglio raccontarvi
una storia la storia
della Yotobi dance
ma partiamo dall'inizio più precisamente
nel 2011 io facevo ancora le recensioni
YouTube Italia era appena esplosa e ci
si metteva ancora le parrucche era
effettivamente un bel periodo era un
periodo in cui potevi fare qualsiasi
cosa sul canale senza essere mangiato
vivo ed è nell'agosto di quell'anno che
faccio la conoscenza di un gruppo di
ragazzi su YouTube Gli useless Insomma
un nome che lasciava presagire il tutto
loro erano un piccolissimo canale che
caricava video nonsense e siccome ci
eravamo conosciuti di persona uno dei
primissimi raduni di YouTube Italia per
chi non lo sapesse molto prima delle
fiere per youtuber c'erano i raduni cioè
dove si radunavano appunto un gruppo di
youtuber senza pubblico solo tra di loro
per conoscersi per fare amicizia e per
scambiarsi idee comunque faccio la
conoscenza degli useless e quindi una
cosa tira l'altra eh Ciao Sono qui
Yotobi quello che fa le recensioni Ah
ciao belli video e grazie pure i vostri
de va bene Vuoi fare un video con noi oh
OK e quindi
e non solo sui Meme ma proprio di fare I
Meme nella vita vera Ah lo so lo so
erano altri tempi quindi ci ritroviamo
giriamo il video ma prima di farlo
uscire decidono di mettere un teaser un
piccolissimo video comico noses che
preannunciava il mio arrivo nel loro
canale che finiva però in un modo
Ah no
già questo teaser non aveva attirato
l'attenzione del pubblico per il teaser
in sé quanto per quel pezzettino di
danza che avevo fatto a fine video Ma da
dove viene questa cosa qui finalmente ve
lo posso dire durante le riprese del
video dei meme ho Perdonatemi c'è gente
che si incazza se li chiami Meme ma
proprio fa delle Campagne dove ti
insulta la madre e la zia se li chiami
Meme quindi solo per voi dico Mmm c'è
una scena in un parco e siccome dovevamo
mettere a fuoco la scena il cameraman mi
dice Mettiti lì davanti e stai un attimo
fermo che metto a fuoco e io molto
simpaticamente invece faccio un
movimento di una frazione di secondo e
poi vado via Questa è la vera YouTube
Dance dura talmente poco che se
starnutisci non la riesci a vedere ed
era talmente scema che i ragazzi della
Juve hanno deciso di farci un loop
mettendoci una musica molto che ci in
sottofondo e come dicevo prima la gente
era uscita di cervello per quel
pezzettino di video tant'è che i ragazzi
per capitalizzare sull'evento è
furbacchioni il 31 agosto 2011 fanno
uscire il video Yotobi dance
e poi un mese dopo il 20 settembre 2011
esce Finalmente il video sui Meme sui
mims E fin qui niente di eccessivamente
strano se non che come ovvio che sia
alla gente piacciono le stronzate e
quindi il video della YouTube Dance fa
molte più Visual del video ufficiale
Abbiamo appena riassunto YouTube in 10
secondi e la storia in teoria finisce
qui Passano gli anni e non succede nulla
o così credevo ma andiamo avanti il
tempo ed arriviamo al 5 febbraio 2015
quattro anni dopo mi sveglio una mattina
completamente ricoperto di notifiche su
Facebook su Twitter molti più del
normale Ecco mo che cazzo è successo Ma
han chiuso il canale Manca il gelato
tutti i video mi è morta la mamma Tra
l'altro mi fa piacere aver scoperto le
mie priorità canale video e poi al terzo
posto mamma solo al terzo posto bene
così niente di tutto ciò mi erano
arrivati una marea di messaggi
riguardanti una mia apparizione in un
video di Pewdiepie io ero nel panico ho
detto Non è possibile che si siano
sbagliati in così tanti deve essere un
malinteso Vabbè che sono molto attraente
molto bello ma scambiarmi per Marzia mi
sembra esagerato No a quanto pare in un
frammento del video di Pewdiepie in un
momento catartico del Gameplay appaiono
io nella mia YouTube Dance a testa in
giù In alto a sinistra
per un brevissimo istante in un’immagine
molto molto piccola ma eccomi lì in quel
momento mi stava scoppiando il cervello
perché Certo mi ricordavo dell'aiuto
bidet dance Ma come era possibile che
fossi lì dentro cioè vuol dire che più
di paesi è messo a ritagliare il video
frame per frame per riuscire a metterlo
per una frazione di secondo mi sembrava
molto strano perché alcuni miei amici mi
hanno detto no no non è così e il tuo
green screen detto come com'è il mio
green screen Eh sì la tua YouTube Dance
che da un po' di tempo che si trova su
YouTube in green screen Ed eccolo qui
video caricato il primo giugno 2014 ed
ecco come ha fatto a mettermi nel suo
video e Ok Ma la domanda rimane Come
cazzo ha fatto a trovare proprio quei
video lì le risposte sono due La prima è
che se tu cerchi su YouTube Dance green
screen senza mettere gli otoby senza
mettere cose strane semplicemente dance
green screen
uno dei primissimi video che appare e
proprio il mio quindi probabilmente in
fase di montaggio Pewdiepie si è messo a
scrivere dance green screen e ha trovato
il primo video sotto mano e l'ha messo
secondo opzione mentre stavo pensando di
fare un video su questa storia qua si è
aggiunto un tassello molto inquietante
mentre parlavo con un mio amico è uscita
la domanda ma chissà come cavolo sono
finito nel video di Pewdiepie La sua
risposta è stata tu sei nei pack mlg di
YouTube
né che cosa per chi fosse sano di mente
e guardasse soltanto video normali c'è
una categoria di video su YouTube
chiamata i video mlg che come
spiegarvelo cosa sono Guarda Faccio
prima a farvene vedere un pezzettino
e vi confesso che questi tipi di video
mi fanno impazzire mi intrattengono da
morire e sono una persona di merda per
questo comunque senza dilungarmi troppo
sappiate che questi momenti mlg in
questi tipi di video sono fatti da tanti
micro Video famosi per esempio il
noscope o litmark di Modern Warfare 2
pacchetti di dorito su Snoop Dogg che
canta Smoke Weed Everyday bibondi Bibbi
Bobbi e tante altre cose spettacolari e
queste micro clip in green screen per
facilitare il lavoro a chi volesse fare
questo tipo di video vengono raccolte in
delle playlist Io sono in molte delle
playlist dei pacchetti mlg di YouTube in
mezzo a Snoop Dogg in mezzo ai no stop
ce la Yotobi dance ed infatti un sacco
di gente negli ultimi due anni mi Ha
linkato video di famosi canali che
caricano video mlg con me dentro
o muori da youtuber o vivi tanto a lungo
da diventare un punto
è questo il finale della storia della
Yotobi dance una storia fatta di
tradimenti di intrighi di passioni non
corrisposte di green screen e di
pacchetti di doritos Però c'è un altro
tassello che mi piacerebbe aggiungere a
questa storia qua mentre la stavo
scrivendo è successo qualcosa in Italia
è morta Tiziana Cantone ora non
fraintendetemi non voglio farvi
assolutamente nessuna morale Però la
storia di Tiziana mi ha fatto pensare
perché se un piccolo stupidissimo video
di una mezza danza per mettere a fuoco
una telecamera ha fatto questo giro
nell'arco di 5 anni che è finita nel
circuito internazionale di YouTube tra
le mani di gente che non sa chi io sia
né da dove sia partita quella cosa lì
immaginatevi soltanto il giro che
potrebbe fare in pochissimo tempo un
video come quello di Tiziana Cantone e
queste cose succedevano Ben prima di
internet basti pensare per esempio
quello Cosa è successo a Marco Masini o
a Mia Martini che qualcuno sicuramente
per Scherzo semplicemente per fare una
battuta dice Ah quello là porta sfiga e
ripeto nessuna morale da parte mia lungi
da me anzi non sono neanche alla persona
adatta per fare questo genere di
discorsi Volevo solo farvi notare come
una cosa così piccola e così
insignificante possa essere cambiate
plasmata talmente tanto che nessuno si
ricorda più da dove sia partita Grazie
mille per aver ascoltato questa storia e
noi ci rivediamo sempre qui
merda
allora